la dernière fois on a parlé de l'ia de
youtube celle qui suggèrent les vidéos à
gauche de celle ci et qui vous a
peut-être suggérer la vidéo que vous
êtes en train de regarder
il semblerait que l'objectif de satire
souhaite avant tout de garder votre
attention pour que vous continuez à
regarder youtube
son but est votre addiction à youtube
imaginez maintenant que vous soyez à la
place de satire et imaginez que vous
disposiez de deux types de vidéos
disons les vidéos bleus et les vidéos
rouge ses couleurs peuvent correspondre
à des partis politiques ou à des styles
communique versus romantique ou à des
sujets matt versus informatique
bref vous avez deux types de vidéos à
proposer et à chaque instant il vous
faut proposer une collection de vidéos
qui est une certaine combinaison des
deux types de vidéos bon pour commencer
vous allez peut-être proposer 50 50 mais
petit à petit si vous voyez qu'un
utilisateur clique plus souvent sur les
vidéos bleus vous allez peut-être alors
vouloir augmenter la proportion de
vidéos bleus proposé et vous voyez le
danger au fur et à mesure il semble y
avoir un risque que vous ne propose y
est plus que des vidéos bleus à
l'utilisateur auquel cas l'utilisateur
sera enfermée dans un certain style de
vidéos il sera dans ce que l'on appelle
une filter bubble que je vais appeler
pour aujourd'hui une fixation aux vidéos
bleus et bien sûr il aurait aussi pu
lier avoir une fixation aux vidéos rouge
en fait le danger est un peu plus subtil
encore imaginer que la condition
initiale soit 50 50 et que l'utilisateur
clique au hasard parmi les vidéos
proposées les fluctuations statistiques
vont faire que l'utilisateur va sans
doute clip est légèrement plus souvent
sur une couleur que l'autre même si ces
clics sont aléatoires melia de youtube
pourrait alors sur interpréter cela et
malgré tout augmenter la proportion de
la couleur la plus cliqués typiquement
si on clique comme au hasard vous avez
légèrement plus cliquez sur les vidéos
rouge alors lié à vous proposera
peut-être 40% de vidéos bleus et 60% de
rouge mais alors si l'utilisateur
continue à cliquer au hasard il va
maintenant cliquer plus souvent sur le
rouge que sur le bleu tout bêtement
parce qu'on lui propose plus de rouge
que de bleu élire pourrait à nouveau
interprété cela comme une préférence
pour le rouge et ainsi continuer à
augmenter la proportion de rouge
on parle alors de dynamique deux tirages
par renforcement dans le sens où ce qui
a été cliqué se trouve être renforcées
dans les tirages suivent
et une question fondamentale que l'on
peut se poser est la suivante un tirage
pas renforcement va-t-il conduire à une
fixation
à quelles conditions il ya de youtube
conduira-t-elle inéluctablement au
filter bubbles et bien il se trouve que
dans un cadre plus formel ces questions
fascinantes ont fait l'objet de la thèse
de doctorat du plus grand youtuber
mathématiciens de youtube francophone
j'ai nommé le génialissime michael
launay aujourd'hui on va parler
notamment du théorème delaunay et j'ai
un invité très spécial pour vous en
parler
bonjour l'est alors effectivement il se
trouve que j'ai fait ma thèse sur ce que
l'on appelle des processus de hasard
renforcé pour comprendre ce que c'est on
va prendre une urne ou comme ça ici dans
laquelle on va mettre une boule rouge à
une boule bleue pour commencer et on va
faire des tirages au sort dans cette
tuerie par exemple ici je vais tirer une
boule au hasard et je vais tomber sur la
rouge
et si je tombe sur la rouge et bien je
vais à la remettre à l'intérieur mais je
vais en rajouter en plus une autre de la
même couleur de sorte que j'ai
maintenant deux rouges et une bleue et
donc si je refais un autre tirage au
sort forcément j'ai plus de chances de
tomber à nouveau sur une rouge donc je
vais en rajouter encore une rouge à
l'intérieur et je vais continuer ce
processus pendant un certain nombre
d'états pendant un très grand nombre
d'étapes et même jusqu'à l'infini est
une des questions qu'on peut se poser
sur ce processus c'est à l'infini quel
va être par exemple la proportion de
boules rouges de boule bleue dans l'urne
qu'en penses tu alors pour tout vous
dire michael m'avait déjà posé cette
question il ya quelques mois appelée
azur et j'étais très surpris par la
réponse à cette question parce qu'a
priori j'aurais parié que l'on aurait
inéluctablement une fixation
c'est-à-dire qu'elle infinie lui on ne
serait quasiment uniquement tout rouge
où quasiment tout bleu j'aurais parié
qu'à cause du renforcement toute
proportion équilibrée est improbable et
j'ai été très content d'apprendre que
mon intuition était très erronée et oui
en effet alors ce processus de
remplissage d'urnes a été étudié en 1930
par le mathématicien georges polliat et
le résultat c'est que la proportion nos
boules rouges de boule bleue dans l'urne
à l'infini n'est ni 0/2 1 mais un nombre
aléatoire compris entre 0 et 1 et le
plus surprenant c'est que n'importe
laquelle des valeurs comprises entre 0
et 1 à la même probabilité de tomber
autrement dit à la limite la proportion
de boules rouges
l'urne va être une variable aléatoire
uniformément répartie entre 0 et 1
et oui j'ai trouvé ça très surprenant ne
serait ce parce que je ne m'attendais
pas vraiment à ce que la proportion de
boules rouges convergent et campus à
face une jolie distribution tout simple
c'est très surprenant et très joli mais
que se passerait-il si on suppose
maintenant qu'il y avait initialement
une certaine proportion de boules rouges
et bleus dans le cas général où il ya
plusieurs boules rouges ou plusieurs
bleus dès le départ comme par exemple
ici 2 et 2 est bien la proportion de
boules rouges dans l'urne à l'infini va
encore une fois tendre vers une certaine
limite mais cette limite cette fois va
être répartie selon une autre
distribution qu'on appelle la
distribution bêta mais on peut peut-être
éviter ces détails techniques pour
aujourd'hui kull donc si je récapitule
en gros si la force de la couleur rouge
est le nombre de fois qu'elle a été
tirée alors à l'infini il n'y aura pas
vraiment de fixation il y aura une
disproportion entre boule rouge et bleu
mes boules rouges et bleus resteront en
quantité comparable
les connaît et il maintenant lorsque la
force d'une couleur n'est pas tout à
fait le nombre de fois qu'elle a été
tiré ça c'est une question que plusieurs
chercheurs se sont posés imaginer qu'on
reprenne notre urnes comme ceci avec une
boule rouge et une boule bleue quand on
tire la boule rouge pour la première
fois et bien on la remet et on en
rajoute une supplémentaire comme ceci
mais maintenant si je retire une boule
rouge pour la deuxième fois et bien non
seulement je vais la remettre mais cette
fois ci je vais en rajouter deux
nouvelles routes comme ceux ci et plus
généralement quand je vais tirer une
boule rouge pour la énième fois
eh bien je vais rajouter and good rouge
à l'intérieur de l'urne
avec ces nouvelles règles du jeu que se
passe-t-il maintenant intuitivement
cette fois le renforcement sera beaucoup
plus conséquent si une boule rouge a été
tiré une fois on n'aura pas n plus une
boule rouge comme avant cette fois on
aura une boule rouge plus une boule
rouge pour la provoc a été tiré puis
deux boules rouges pour la seconde fois
puis trois boules rouges et ainsi de
suite jusqu'à une boule rouge pour la
énième fois que la boule rouge a été
tiré au total le nombre de boules rouges
sera un plus un plus de plus 3 + 4 et
ainsi de suite jusqu'à n
ce qui fait environ hannecart est divisé
par deux boules rouges
on peut donc considérer que la force
d'une couleur est à peu près égale au
carré du nombre de fois où cette couleur
a été tiré on parle dans ce cas là de
renforcement quadratique
et du coup mickaël en cas de
renforcement quadratique aura-t-on
fixation et bien la réponse est oui dans
ce cas le renforcement est si fort que
l'on finira forcément par ne plus tirer
qu'une seule des deux couleurs
on a donc bien fixation donc
intuitivement j'imagine qu'il en serait
de même pour un renforcement cubique kw
arctique ou exponentielle la question
qui est maintenant intéressante c'est
qu'en est il du cas entre laurent
forcément linéaire qui est celui des
autres apparaît au début et le
renforcement codra tic et bien en 1990
le mathématicien beurre jesse davis a
montré une condition nécessaire et
suffisante pour qu'il y ait fixation
cette jolie condition est la suivante il
y aura fixation si et seulement si la
somme des inverse de la suite de
renforcement convergent à c'est
tellement beau comme théo rennes on a
une question intrigante et non trivial
et ce théorème en fournit une réponse
simple et élégante
d'ailleurs il ya un truc plus jolie
encore que le théorème c'est la preuve
du théorème par herrmann ou bing
oui c'est vrai cette preuve est
absolument magnifique et d'ailleurs
cette preuve fait partie des raisons
pour lesquelles j'ai voulu faire ma
thèse sur ce sujet absolument fascinant
bon malheureusement la preuve guerre
quelques connaissances pour être bien
expliqué donc on ne va pas pour la
présenter ici mais bon je serrais de
faire un épisode hardcore pas de
promesses ceci dit la recherche dans le
domaine ne s'est pas arrêté là puisque
michael aura apporté sa pierre à
l'édifice en prouvant de nouveau
théorème oui en gros mois j'ai étudié ce
qui se passe quand on a plusieurs
mesures de renforcement et que ces
différentes urnes interagissent entre
elles et c'est super intéressant parce
que c'est un peu ce qui se passe sur
youtube
de temps en temps il va y avoir une
vidéo qui va faire un énorme buzz et qui
risque alors d'atteindre la sphère
youtube de gens qui ne sont pas
forcément intéressés à priori c'est
comme si chaque utilisateur youtube
avait une urne de vidéos et que la vidéo
en trending étaient tirées de l'ensemble
de toutes les urnes et s'appliquer à
tous c'est en tout cas un des modèles
que j'ai étudié pendant ma thèse on
considère plusieurs urnes avec un
renforcement exponentielle et avec une
probabilité paix on va tirer une boule
dans toutes les urnes réunis comme s'il
s'agissait que d'une seule très grosse
urnes et avec probabilité 1 - paix on va
tirer la boule dans l'urne toute seule
indépendamment
autrement dit selon le paramètre paix
est bien les urnes doit être plus ou
moins liées entre elles ou plus ou moins
indépendantes et donc le théorème
delaunay
ou plutôt l'un des théorèmes delaunay
prédit les fixations ou non des urnes
dans ce cadre en fonction notamment de
la probabilité d'interaction paix entre
les urnes
oui alors déjà six pay plus grand qu'un
demi ce qui signifie que les urnes
interagissent beaucoup comme le
renforcement est exponentielle ce qui
est très fort et bien on peut imaginer
que toutes les urnes vont se fixer au
bout d'un certain temps sur la même
couleur et c'est effectivement ce que
j'ai démontré
ok mais ça a priori je dirais que ça ne
ressemble pas vraiment le cas de youtube
j'ai plutôt l'impression que les vidéos
trending sont plutôt minoritaire parmi
celles que voient les utilisateurs ce
qui correspondrait plutôt au cap est
inférieur à 1 2 me et bien dans ce cas
j'ai démontré que les urnes allait se
diviser en deux catégories d'un côté il
va y avoir des urnes qu'on peut appeler
des journaux conformiste qui vont se
fixer sur la couleur qui est globalement
majoritaire et de l'autre côté il va y
avoir des urnes au complet appelé
anticonformiste qui vont se fixer sur
une autre couleur de leur choix les
urnes au conformisme ne verront alors
que des vidéos de la couleur majoritaire
tandis que les urnes anticonformiste
verrons un peu des deux vidéos avec
probabilité paie donc dans une minorité
des cas elles verront des vidéos de la
couleur majoritaire mais avec
probabilité un mois p eh bien elles
verront des vidéos de la couleur
qu'elles ont choisi et c'est très
intéressant tout ça ça montre qu'en cas
d'interaction faible un renforcement
exponentielle qui soit dit en passant
correspond à la formule 2 bis naïve que
pourrait calculer unia
comme il ya de youtube ce renforcement
exponentielle a de bonnes chances de
conduire à une ségrégation des
utilisateurs certains utilisateurs
pourraient ainsi finir par regarder des
vidéos conformiste tandis que d'autres
ne serait exposé qu'à des vidéos
anticonformiste alors loin de moi
l'envié de dire que le conformisme c'est
bien ou mal et que l'anti conformisme
c'est bien mal ce que je trouve
important à signaler c'est que cette
issue pourrait n'être qu'une conséquence
directe de l'utilisation d'une ia en
charge de la recommandation de vidéos
youtube mais aussi d'articles
d'actualité ou de blogs notamment
lorsque satire cherche uniquement à
suggérer des vidéos qui vont plaire aux
utilisateurs et tout ça ça marche pour
des utilisateurs qui cliquent
aléatoirement sur des vignettes youtube
qu'on leur montre or les sciences
sociales ne cesse de montrer que nous
autres humains sommes beaucoup plus
influençables qu'un chimpanzé qui
expliquerait aléatoirement comme on en a
beaucoup parlé dans la série sur la
démocratie
a tendance à être victime du biais de
confirmation et de l'hooliganisme
politique qui nous pousse à nous
conforter dans ce que l'on croit déjà
tout ça pour dire que pour plaire aux
utilisateurs unis a comme l'ia de
youtube aura très probablement d'autant
plus intérêt à implémenter un
renforcement exponentielle dès lors le
théorème delaunay semble au moins
partiellement s'appliquer auquel cas on
s'attend à constater l'émergence de
bulles d'anticonformisme qui s'opposent
à une bulle majoritaire de conformiste
et en particulier conformiste et
anticonformiste subirait une fixation de
vidéos qui leur sont recommandées
il verrait le monde en bleu ou en rouge
mais pas en une nuance de bleu et de
rouge pour éviter une telle ségrégation
idéologique il faudrait alors absolument
modifié la dynamique de renforcement
voilà qui semble nécessiter une
modification des intentions de l'iran
plutôt que de chercher uniquement à
plaire aux utilisateurs il faudrait
alors implémenter des valeurs morales de
société à lire un énorme merci à michael
notamment pour son intervention dans
cette vidéo pas si vous connaissez pas
mickael sebban chaîne youtube qui marche
du tonnerre et qui est absolument génial
puisque ça parle de maths et c'est en
parlant plus très bien que quand
vivement ces vidéos et pour les plus
motivés par il vous recommande également
la thèse de michael qui est supérieur n
écrite qui est vraiment très très clairs
à très très agréable à lire et qui est
très accessible également qu'à la partie
compréhensible de cette thèse voilà
comme on peut l'imaginer c'est michael
et du coup il ya un effort pédagogique
absolument génial dans cette thèse qui
la rend beaucoup plus libre que d'autres
thèses et évite par exemple petites
annonces avant de passer aux questions
jeu sera au palais de la découverte ce
samedi à 16h pour vous parler du démon
de solomonoff qui le chapitre 7 de mon
livre pour pouvoir assister à
l'événement il faut acheter votre billet
pour le ballet la découverte est ce que
vous donnera aussi l'occasion de visiter
notamment la nouvelle section du palais
de la découverte sur l'informatique d'un
enfant avait déjà parlé de la morale de
lire de youtube et antoine meyer a
anticipé cette vidéo puisqu'il pose une
question sur le fait qu'on puisse
être enfermé dans un ensemble de vidéos
en fait il correspond toujours aux mêmes
youtuber si on a une certaine youtuber
et ça nous empêche de découvrir d'autres
youtuber typiquement et ça ça correspond
à un champ de recherche qui pose la
question de comment inclure une
diversité dans les suggestions des
années intelligence artificielle que ce
soit sur youtube amazon ou autre et
c'est quelque chose d'assez intéressant
puisque ça correspond déjà à quelque
chose de un peu plus subtil pour les
intelligences artificielles qui ne
doivent pas uniquement de maximiser le
click to wait qui est le jean que le
fait que les gens vous cliquez sur ce
qui est suggéré qu'un peu la métrique
une des métriques en tout cas de base
qui sont utilisés par les systèmes de
recommandation en général là il s'agit
non seulement de regarder si les gens
vont piquer mais aussi s'ils vont être
amenés à découvrir d'autres genres du
coup à peut-être plus cliquez dans le
futur deux cas c'est pas évident que
juste en regardant les clics des
utilisateurs ils soient faciles
d'inférer est-ce que tant qu'il ya
est-ce que j'ai intérêt à proposer plus
de diversité ou non faut vraiment
finalement que ça soit on connaît
directement dans lla que d'aucuns taille
fournit des réponses
il lui est préférable de toujours
proposer une certaine diversité
bref tout ça pour dire que c'est un vrai
problème mais il ya des chercheurs qui
travaillent dessus et je vous renvoie
notamment vers une interview zeta bike
ce que j'ai fait avec docteur élise
assez lisse qui travaillait le pfl match
car on lui demande c'est plutôt que de
chercher à programmer la morale des ja
il ne faudrait pas plutôt essayer de
faire en sorte qu'un grand nombre de
gens soient beaucoup plus formés aux
nouvelles technologies est vraiment
l'intelligence artificielle et et soit
dotée d'une éthique solide très
clairement je pense que ça serait bien
si plus de gens réfléchissent et
davantage aux tous les enjeux éthiques
et moraux chercher davantage à voir des
raisonnements qui sont cohérents autant
que possible et chercher autant que
possible à exprimer leurs conceptions de
la morale de façon aussi claire que
possible et ça serait encore mieux si
ces personnes comprenait tous les enjeux
qui était lié à l'intelligence
artificielle en particulier comment
chercher à maîtriser intelligence
artificielle en fonction de cette
conception de
un oral mais c'est un problème
extrêmement difficile y compris chez les
experts de la morale et de
l'intelligence artificielle est d'une
certaine manière j'ai c'est de
contribuer à cet effort en faisant ces
vidéos cette folle et j'espère que vous
les partager pour contribuer également à
ces efforts malheureusement ça
m'étonnerait qu'on arrive à avoir une
fraction non négligeable de la
population qui s'intéresse vraiment à
ces questions et qu'ils le fassent et
qu'ils réfléchissent vraiment bien j'ai
envie de dire à ces questions et qui ne
s'enferme pas sur des trucs du 20e
siècle a typiquement en particulier si
je raisonne en termes d'altruisme et
efficace il me semble qu'aujourd'hui
tout cas mon échelle individuelle
vraiment le meilleur truc que je puisse
faire pour avoir le meilleur influence
positive sur le fait que le monde ira
mieux et maîtrisera bien ces nouvelles
technologies en fera plutôt du bien que
du mal il me semble vraiment que ma
priorité personnelle là où je peux avoir
le plus d'effet
c'est essayer de convaincre la plupart
des ingénieurs et des chercheurs qu'il
s'agit en effet d'un énorme problème est
qu'il faut absolument bien poser le
problème est du coup les accompagner
autant que possible dans l'infection
autour de cela pour qu'ensuite ces
gens-là fasse en sorte que les
intelligences artificielles qui le
programme et des valeurs morales dans
leurs fonctions objectif
j'ai bien peur malheureusement que
aujourd'hui compter sur le citoyen
lambda
aujourd'hui moi j'aimerais bien j'ai
vraiment envie que le mec soit vraiment
très très à l'aise avec le concept
d'intelligence artificielle est vraiment
bien réfléchi à la morale
malheureusement
ça me paraît très difficile de passer
par l'éducation nationale aujourd'hui
c'est juste impossible et touché un
grand public aujourd'hui c'est très
difficile du coup bah je fais ce que je
peux et il me semble que pour un sens la
meilleure chose à faire c'est vraiment
déjà que les gens qui sont dans le
domaine se sentent plus concernés par
ces problèmes de morale
enfin joël beckham nous demande aussi
l'un des grands problèmes de société
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas plutôt la
surconsommation des ressources et en
effet c'est un énorme problème et je
vous renvoie vers une nombreuses vidéos
du réveil or pour en savoir plus sur les
problèmes de surconsommation
en fait il faut bien voir que
l'utilisation de ressources pour faire
avancer des causes morales a aussi un
coût moral qui est tout simplement
l'utilisation de cette ressource
du coup l'utilisation de cette ressource
sera justifiée si elle permet davantage
de faire du bien que du mal avec les
conséquences environnementales notamment
donc typiquement si je prends un exemple
est-ce qu'il faut prendre un 4 4 pour
faire 100 m bah ça correspond à un coût
environnemental est ça ne correspond pas
une conséquence bénéfique pour la
société que diviser le 4-4 et du coup
avec la zone dont conséquent ces listes
ont conclu que bath est mal utilisée en
quête pour faire 100 m bon je prends un
exemple un peu débile mais c'est pour
vous montrer que l'on le cadre du
conséquentialiste cette consommation des
ressources et notamment les conséquences
néfastes de la consommation des
ressources est parfaitement prise en
compte par ce raisonnement il faut juste
bien le modéliser vous avez aimé cet
épisode concerne le hacker le
commentaire le partage et pensez à vous
abonner pour ne pas manquer les futurs
épisodes
merci au type heures pot l'ordre et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois la dernière fois que youtube a
communiqué c'était un septembre 2016
2016 ils ont publié un papier
scientifique qui s'appelait d'hypnose
network fois youtube recommandations qui
est donc un papier destiné à des
scientifiques pas du tout destiné aux
youtube à la sopat juan challenge to
provide enough precision statique match
et sur interest rates of discovery soda